assis sur un pupitre en balançant les
jambes molles ne réfléchissait au bon
moment il rit aussi mais doucement comme
si lui réserver ses éclats de rire pour
quelques meilleures histoires connues de
lui seul
puis à la nuit tombante lorsque la lueur
des carreaux de la classe n'éclairait
plus le groupe confus de jeunes gens
meaulnes se levait soudain et traverser
le cercle pressé allons en route
criait-il bonsoir et bienvenue à épines
aigles fleuriel dans le sud du
département du cher le village où est né
en 1913
l'un des personnages majeurs de la
littérature française
augustin maulde ce roman le grand
meaulnes est l'oeuvre d'alain fournier
né en 1886 à la chapelle d'angillon
également dans le cher mais c'est bien
ici à épineuil le fleuriel que tout a
commencé dans cette maison école où
alain fournier fut l'élève de son père
instituteur et c'est logiquement une
institutrice qui nous ouvre les portes
de la maison école du grand meaulnes
bienvenue à la maison école du grand
moun
[Musique]
voici donc cette école on monsieur
fournier fut nommé instituteur en 1891
où la famille s'installa et le jeune
henri fournier qui n'était pas encore
alain fournier écrit qu'il passa ici les
jours les plus chers et les plus
tourmentés 10 amis
[Musique]
e
et
c'est la pièce des grands la classe que
dirige monsieur fournier et le jeune
fournier sera son élève jusqu'en 1898
lorsqu'il part en sixième au lycée
voltaire à paris dans le grand moun
il va utiliser ses camarades de classe
les habitants du village les lieux du
villaret de la campagne environnante
parfois ils gardent et il donne aux gens
leur propre nom parfois il ya un
transfert de nom d'un camarade sur un
autre d'une personne sur ans sur une
autre mais comme il l'écrit tout ce que
j'écris se passe quelque part
[Musique]
voici la mansarde où le jeune henri
fournier va coucher à partir de cette de
l'âge de 7 ans et il va être
impressionné par tout cet univers par
les bruits les bruits du vent de la
pluie du tonnerre par les éclairs et
puis surtout il est entouré des greniers
et il parlera du silence des trois
grenier est à mon avis la genèse du
roman commence dans cette mansarde
puisqu'il parlera du royaume qu'il s'y
était découvert
et bien après cette visite on se
retrouve ici à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de epineuil le fleuriel mais
toujours avec notre guide et ancienne
institutrice andré lhuillier vous avez
choisi ce lieu
sainte agathe et cette chapelle cela
mérite des explications c'est à
l'intérieur durant bol qu'on la trouve
bien oui puisque le village le nom du
village d'épineuil va être masqué sur
celui de sainte agathe
et si alain fournier a choisi sainte
agathe c'est un lieu qui le faisait
rêver
il y avait des pèlerinages très
important où les gens d'épineuil se
rendait mais est en fils de hussards
noirs de la république
il était absolument interdit à la
famille fournier de pouvoir assister à
ce pèlerinage
et c'est ainsi qu'il l'écrit que la tête
appuyée au barreau du portail
il regardait passer sur le chemin jaune
les pèlerins de sainte-agathe la vie de
alain fournier s'arrête en 1914 dans les
tranchées de la meuse la parution du
grand meaulnes c'est 1913 il ne
connaîtra pas l'énorme succès
l'extraordinaire succès de ce monument
de la littérature française mais
néanmoins dès lors qu'il l'écrit il sait
que ce roman est symbolique
oui et il en fait il a été exaucé
puisque il écrivait je ne veux ni prix
ni argent je voudrais que le grand monde
fut donc il a été exaucé
merci beaucoup andré mulliez pour cette
visite à épineuil le fleuriel et pour
votre vision à vous du grand meaulnes
d'alain fournier demain nous quittons
cette région et le cher pour nous rendre
dans le loiret parler de maurice
genevoix l'écrivain entrée au pontet en
2020 et pour parler de son raboliot un
roman qui magnifie la nature et tout
particulièrement la sologne